travis scott apologized to his fans and
families after astroworldfest in today
good evening i'm poppy doppy poppy and
this is peer news i'm back
[Music]
at least eight people dead after crowd
panic at travis scott concert you
probably heard about this already it's
absolutely insane and the more i look
into it the more insane it actually is
so it was reported at travis scott
concert that there was this actual
madness happening mob mentality there
was fires breaking out and very early in
the day as well uh people doing all
kinds of crazy stuff which is normal for
a concert i think and to a certain
extent you can already see people
trampling over each other
i assume this is at the concert
even during the day basically this is
happening actual pure havoc i guess my
point is it's it's normal that things
get out of control that concert but what
is it normal is that no one did anything
about it it blows my mind which
unfortunately i mean it's a tragedy
eight people lost their lives 300 people
were led to the hospital on site and 23
were led uh out of sight and young
young kids lost their lives the youngest
were 14 one was 16 21 27
um
it's just not okay and i haven't seen it
confirmed but i assume people died of
asphyxia of getting choked between the
crowd and this is absolutely nightmare
scenario i don't want to think about it
so awful at a place that's supposed to
be fun and entertaining something like
this happens and the real question here
is you know who is responsible is it the
event organizers or is it travis scott
and i've seen a lot of people argue
about this question online and the
answer is pretty simple they're both
they're both guilty there's no doubt
about it
there's footage proving it because this
is the worst proud
accident incident tragedy
whatever you want to call it
in 40 years in usa but now obviously we
can actually see how it happened with
the people filming and i think
seeing that that's what makes it so
clear and what makes it i don't know so
upsetting as well because normally i
think i would sign with the artists in
situations like this where and say you
know this event organizer's fault
they're the ones responsible they're the
ones who should pull the plug but when
you look into it you see footage of
people trying to contact staff
especially the cameraman and to try and
tell them what's going on and basically
no action was taken out of that as far
as i understood there was people yelling
stopped the show at many times during
the show some of the staff should have
heard that and at least i understand if
travis doesn't hear it i i couldn't
understand that but it blows my mind
dude i think the worst footage is this
one i'm not gonna show
anything more than just i just want to
give you an idea how
close travis was to what was going on
here he is on stage and here basically
is someone getting transported out
unconsciously everyone is looking at it
everyone is paying attention to this not
travis [ __ ] scott he's right there
above the crowd he sees everything a ton
of police officers uh paramedics ton of
stuff going on and what do you have in
the back travis scott doing the robot
amazing well done the thing is i don't
know what it's like to be on that big of
a stage but i have been on stages before
you see the people you see the crowd
everyone's been on stage before you look
at the crowd right that's all you look
out for i don't understand how you can
defend him not seeing it basically
there's no excuse okay uh there's been
many examples we've seen footage of a
ton of other artists who when they see
something going on in the crowd they
yell out stop it youtube break it off or
all right we're not continuing this
because of x y and z there's really no
reason to not stop the show if you see
something going on right watch
yourselves
hey yo man
we know we've been stressing all night
about being cool
and this is the reason why we gotta look
out for safety first for real i think
travis scott thought it was cool how
everything was so crazy and out of
control at his concert that he just
didn't care he probably didn't realize
the severity of the situation to be
devil's advocate but at the same time it
shouldn't matter you're still
responsible when you look after all
these people right and you know when
people are literally twerking on top of
ambulances i don't know is that an
ambulance that seems insane i don't even
believe it maybe that's an indication
that something's going on it's not like
it's impossible to stop a concert is my
point we've seen people doing it for way
less of a reason all the time so people
started noticing all this and then start
questioning travis you know what the
hell why don't you do anything so travis
scott issued an apology and it's
probably the worst apology i've seen in
a very very long time sorry if i'm
smiling or like smirking over this it's
just the whole thing series is so dumb i
don't know how else to react to it i'm
not trying to make light of the
situation by being funny if that's the
case so here's trevor scott apologizing
he's doing these weird things i just
want to send out prayers to the
to the ones that was lost last night
what is that he's doing this weird thing
that kids do when they apologize but
they don't really know how to fake cry
so they just start like rubbing their
face i've definitely seen kids do this
it's so bizarre and also bro it's a
little late for thoughts and prayers
we're actually working right now
to identify the families
so we can help assist them through this
tough time travis takes absolutely zero
responsibility in this apology he's just
saying the opposite of what happened you
know my fans my fans like my fans really
mean the world to me and my fans mean
the world to me also i'm doing the robot
while they are unconscious it's like
it's like shooting a guy and then just
saying i really care about people's
safety i want people to live i really
care about people living like bro no i
always just really want to leave them
with a positive experience positive any
time i can make out
you know anything that's going on you
know you know i just stopped the show
and
you know help them get the help they
need you know bra
[Music]
so he's saying here anytime that i can
notice anything going on you know eight
people
ambulances going back and forth sirens
paramedics people yelling stop he just
didn't notice any of it if he had
noticed it he would have done something
for sure i mean how could he not have
done anything
bro you're lying dude i could just never
imagine the severity of the situation i
believe that
i believe he didn't realize how bad it
was i don't think anyone with the right
mind
if eight people have died and they know
about it they wouldn't continue to the
show at least i'd like to think that
we've been working closely
uh we've been working closely with
everyone to just try to get to the
bottom of this city houston hpd
fire department
means you have to understand that means
absolutely
it doesn't matter how it happened people
understand that concert can get out of
control the problem is that no action
was taken when it was happening that's
the whole issue it doesn't matter at
this point dude everyone uh
you know help us
help us figure this out so if you
if you have any information
um
you know please just contact your local
authorities what's that gonna do nothing
anyway he just keeps going going on
rubbing his face it's so weird i could
never imagine anything like this just
happening i rate this apology absolutely
dogs get zero out of ten yeah i think he
didn't realize how bad it was but he
definitely saw people being injured so
it doesn't matter and i think the people
seeing how big this event was i didn't
realize i'm not a travis scott fan so
i didn't realize how big it was see how
huge the concert is i mean i think the
people behind the scenes they were just
trying to keep it going because they
want to don't want to refund tickets
right if they have to cancel it it's
absolutely money involved that was part
of the reason for this happening fans
meant the world to him why didn't he
stop the show when they asked he just he
just didn't hear it there's no way he
could realize honestly a better apology
would have been to just say you know
what i was drugged out of my mind that's
what i do on concerts i honestly
couldn't tell anything i trusted my
event organized i don't know anything
would have been bad and then it is what
is that
anyway what do you think leave a comment
down below i see you tomorrow bye bye
poppy out